tenemos esta balanza en equilibrio como
puedes ver y la pregunta que tenemos es
acerca de esta masa misteriosa la azul
que está aquí y también tenemos muchas
masas de un kilógramo éstas que están
aquí todas son iguales y la pregunta que
te quiero hacer es qué podríamos hacer
para saber el valor de esta masa
misteriosa ya sea quitar o poner cosas
de un lado o del otro o realmente
podremos saberlo esto es pensar en que
podemos hacer en todo lo que podamos
hacer para encontrar el valor de esta
masa misteriosa y te voy a dar algunos
segundos para pensar en esto
pues para saber el valor de esta masa
misteriosa lo que tendríamos que hacer
es dejarla sola de este lado de la
balanza si quitamos estos tres que están
del lado izquierdo pues no es suficiente
algo más tenemos que hacer al quitar
estos tres del lado izquierdo
entonces el lado izquierdo de la balanza
será más ligero e irá para arriba y el
lado izquierdo será más pesado y bajará
y esto solo revelaría que el lado
izquierdo es más ligero que el lado
derecho no nos daría más información no
nos diría cuál es el valor de la masa
misteriosa si lo que buscamos es
mantener la balanza en equilibrio
entonces tendremos que quitar la misma
cantidad de masa del lado izquierdo y
del lado derecho para mantener el
equilibrio así que voy a quitar tres de
este lado izquierdo a ver mejor voy a
cambiar por el borrador y al quitarlos
la masa total del lado izquierdo es
menor que la del lado derecho si lo que
queremos es conservar el equilibrio
entonces tendremos que quitar 3
de ambos lados si iniciamos con una
balanza en equilibrio y quitamos tres de
ambos lados
conservaremos el equilibrio
y al hacer esto podremos saber cuál es
el valor de la masa del lado izquierdo
porque será igual a lo que quedó del
lado derecho así que contemos lo que
quedó 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 y si cada uno de
ellos tiene un valor de un kilogramo
entonces la masa de este objeto es igual
a 7 kilogramos esto vale 7